HAVE DIGITALLY MANIPULATED
JIHADI JOHN'S VOICE.
IN THE ISIS BEHEADING VIDEOS,
THE MILITANT KNOWN AS JIHADI
JOHN HAS A DEEP, MENACING VOICE.
>> OBAMA, YOU HAVE STARTED THIS.
IT'S ONLY RIGHT WE CONTINUE TO
STRIKE THE NECKS OF YOUR PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: BUT IS THIS THE
SAME MAN?
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
JEWS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THEIR
RELIGION?
LOOK, THEY'RE A RELIGION.
>> Reporter: AN AUDIO RECORDING
OF THE MAN WE BELIEVE IS
26-YEAR-OLD MOHAMMED EMWAZI WAS
JUST RELEASED BY AN ACTIVIST
GROUP FOR SUSPECTED RADICALS
WHICH CLAIMS IT WORKED WITH
EMWAZI.
CNN CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY
THE AUDIO SEFRMT T EXCERPTS.
THE GUARDIAN NEWSPAPER BELIEVE
EMWAZI IS THIS MAN.
CAGE SAID THEY RECORDED HIM IN
2009 TALKING ABOUT BEING
INTERROGATING BY BRITAIN'S
DOMESTIC INTELLIGENCE SERVICE.
EMWAZI SAID HE WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE DEADLY 2005 TERROR ATTACK IN
LONDON WHERE MORE THAN 50 PEOPLE
DIED?
>> HE GOES, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
7/7?
I SAID, MAN, WHAT INNOCENT
PEOPLE HAVE DIED, MAN, WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
THIS IS XEXTREMISM.
OKAY, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
WAR IN AFGHANISTAN?
WHAT DO I THINK?
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE BEING
KILLED.
HE SAID, WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
9/11?
I SAID, THIS IS A WRONG THING.
>> DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE HE
THOUGHT THAT WAS WRONG OR DID HE
SAY WHAT HE WANTED THE
INTERROGATORS TO HEAR?
>> IF YOU'D BE THE STUPIDEST
RADICAL ALIVE TO ADMIT TO HAVING
EXTREMIST VIEWS TO A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL.
HE WANTED TO GET OUT OF THAT
SITUATION.
>> Reporter: EMWAZI CLAIMS HIS
INTERROGATOR THOUGHT HE WAS
TRYING TO GO TO SOMALIA TO TRAIN
WITH A TERROR GROUP.
>> TRYING TO PUT WORDS IN MY
MOUTH SAYING NO, YOU'RE DOING
THIS THIS THIS AND THIS, WE'RE
KEEPING A CLOSE EYE ON YOU.
>> CAGE SAYS IT WAS THOSE
INTERROGATIONS THAT SENT EMWAZI
ON THE PATH TO JIHAD.
>> I THINK CAGE IS TRYING TO
MAKE A POINT AND ATTACK THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT WHEN